من الواضح أن البرازيل الآن هي ثاني
أكثر البلدان تأثراً في العالم
بفيروس كورونا بعد ظهور الأصابع في وقت متأخر من
ليلة السبت والتي يبدو أن
الولايات المتحدة استجابت لها من
حيث
الحالات المؤكدة من خلال حظر
دخول الولايات المتحدة لأولئك القادمين من البرازيل.  أو أولئك
الذين زاروا البرازيل في آخر 14
يومًا ، يبدو أنه محاولة إلى أجل غير مسمى
لمحاولة منع العدوى هنا من
الوصول إلى الولايات المتحدة
والمساهمة في انتشارها داخل الولايات المتحدة ،
لكن هذه الأخبار السيئة بالطبع
للبرازيليين تأتي  في اليوم الذي شهد
فيه سيناريو رئيسهم ، جربيل ،
مشاهدة مباراة بالقرب من حشود من المؤيدين الذين لا
يرتدون أقنعة ، وتجمع غير متوقع في
برازيليا في مقر الحكومة في
البرازيل ، ورد أنه طار
فوق هذه الحشود في طائرة هليكوبتر ثم
هبط مرتديًا طائرة هليكوبتر.  قناع ثم
تم تصويره لاحقًا إلى جانب أحد
أعضاء مجلس الوزراء واثنين من المشرعين يدعمونه في
تحية مؤيديه ، هذه
عروض شائعة جدًا بواسطة t  إنه رئيس
دعمه في عاصمة الحكومة
وغالبًا ما يتم استخدامه للإشارة إلى أنه
مرتاح بين الأفراد الآخرين
الذين لا يكونون بالضرورة ضروريين
على الرغم من الكارثة المتزايدة داخل
البرازيل نفسها.
بارد لكن البرازيل لا
تزال تبدو على بعد أسبوع إلى أسبوعين من
ذروتها وقيادتها السياسية
تعطي إشارات منقسمة للغاية
بأنفسهم سيناريو الجربوع الرئيسي لا
يرتدي قناعًا هذا اليوم نيك باتون والش
سي إن إن ماناوس البرازيل